[Music]
okay so this is my great pleasure to
introduce Chen Li whom I have known of
course for many years he did his PhD at
Stanford it's now a full professor at UC
Irvine University of California Irvine
and his area like mine has been around
data management system mostly query
processing text analytics and query
processing means both execution and
optimization he was he was he got the
NSF Career Award he was also our program
co-chair for vldb 2015 15 yes and he
also did a startup so he's a full
package so without much for the
introduction Chen take it away and he's
going to talk about two of his research
projects so just thanks for for hosting
my my visit has been a while for me last
time I visited here was more than maybe
five years ago it's good to see all the
old friends also this is I mean your new
faces so the last few years at the
surgit I took some other venture to try
to do a startup to commercialize some of
my work it's a pretty eye-opening
experience pretty interesting and
pressure for people who have done a
start-up before like a dong you know how
it feels and I came back about two or
three years ago and and I that
experienced taught me many things so one
thing I learned was being in academia or
in general in this research a few a
building system is more exciting even
before Peters start off with we together
with my colleague Mike Harry we were
building a open-source project called
acid eb we talked about briefly and and
and after i came back i continued
development that project and also boozes
some other systems so in this talk i
want to use the time to give you all of
you what of what had been doing over the
last few years and i want to make it a
little bit a high-level one maybe one
two places I've become technical but
you're very welcome
some technical details in addition I
talked about two systems and both
systems have demos and I want to spend
about two-thirds of my time on the first
system in a one third of time on the
second system but you we always talk
offline about some of the issues so the
first project is called Club area and
the motivation is about how to support a
big queries in subsections okay I know I
talked to the some of the colleagues
here I know they're a lot of work in
this space and I'm telling you I'm
telling what do we want to do in this
space so at a high level club area is a
general-purpose middleware solution
which can support interactive analytics
and visualization
it supports different kinds of patterns
given databases of course we have the
buyers of supporting and as a DB but
they also support other databases and we
also support different kind of front
ends so even though my demo the first
demo is about kind of a visualization I
want to emphasize this products not
about visualization it's about
supporting visualization for example
tableau can be one of our front end
users okay so I want to start the first
part we with the demo so the demo we are
going to show here is both demos about
social media analysis even though both
solutions are general purpose so for
this demo we call it Twitter map it's
just is one application of club very I
want to differentiate between club every
on to their map because a club area can
support different kinds of applications
for this two term app demo the backend
has about this number of trees close to
1 billion twists collected over one year
and the ten month starting from November
2015 it's about one roughly 1% of all
the us trees okay
still is a small number I know many
people have seen bigger scales but it's
a proof concept and plus the back and
the using parallel solutions
if you have more data which is just
three more Hardware the whole thing is a
scalable so the goal we want to achieve
in this project is for this amount of
data with textual temporal and spatial
conditions and we want allow we want
allow the user to be able to see the
data from different angles by submitting
different kinds of conditions okay so
one example is currently we have this
hurricane Irma coming and here we are
lucky because you are with a north
northwest they were better far from
Florida but let's say we want to see how
the social media is talking about
hurricane okay so we can just type in
the keyword hurricane even though you
can type in any keyword so the user type
in this keyword and want to see all the
trees that the aggregation results a
number of tweets mentioning hurricane
per state
and we shall be the map with the
aggregation results we also showed a
histogram over over given different
amperes so you can see some of the
sample to use here currently it is like
a one forty one and this one later one
of 139 either is real I didn't censor
that twist so don't be offended by that
the worse there is very organic
so the we get some rough idea about the
distribution and given me say what if
you look at the population of one state
and to the division or to the
normalization we can allow to do Naaman
ization to see on the average how many
two years per person talking about
hurricane in each state you can still
get that at the idea still you can see a
Texas of Florida these are two states
that are very people are very concerned
about this this topic
and so you see that the two peaks the
second peaks not surprising there's a
peak here maybe some reason last summer
there was some Timmy hurricane that was
very troublesome so you can just you can
you can pick a range for the time
dimension and then the results will be
updated with those answers within that
time range and you can easily change
your your time window by changing that
the start time or ending time or you can
slide the window and so the user changes
the conditions on a time dimension and
the system can responsibly keep the
results
what is amount of data okay and then
let's say what if the user wants to go
deeper into that data so let's say in in
in in Texas we want to see within Texas
how the trees are geographically located
based on different counties so we go we
zoom in we show all the different
regions which given counties and then
the color indicated that the density of
per County okay and you can go even
further down to even the county level I
pick just one of them and a Houston and
then at this level we never show that
the city level aggregate resource so now
first we show 3d levels but you can you
can define your own hierarchy and we
allow you to zoom in zoom out in this
space dimension and text and in the time
given dimensions and the main thing is
for this one billion of our own building
records which is about one terabyte of
data how can do this kind of queries
within sub seconds so this is the way
one achieve and on the back end this is
the kind of at the mini cluster we are
using now we moved it too much into my
office the back end is running a cluster
of six nuke boxes each one is about
eight hundred dollars with half terabyte
of SSD 16 kilos memory and maybe two
quarter four cores of a card and and we
use heavily relying on a disk or a flash
drive to make a scale up
since the whole infrastructure is a
parallel if you have more data just
three more boxes the total budget is
about less than $5,000 okay so so within
$5,000 we want to deliver is this kind
of user experiences so now let's see
what's happening behind the scene so
this is what what club area is keep
overdoing architecture wise club area is
a meadow where the cysts on top of your
existing database and the the one we saw
just now the back end is using a strip
TP because we have a connector that
talks to the database using our native
language two languages with a bilingual
eql and seek applause and we also
recently get build it one more connector
or two more connectors one talking to my
sequel one plug into a post squeezed far
as the Duke ramen is your database
should provide you got your back-end not
a debase your back-end should provide a
query language either through dwc or a
RESTful API so that the middleware can
talk to you by issuing some queries the
induction will mean some some
assumptions one assumption is that it is
for nice append only once you data
because summer logic relies on
assumption once the data is already in
inserting in your record tables we are
not modify any more and we know a lot of
the cases satisfy this condition we have
one more assumption we show you later
and that the the clobber made it where
does a lot of techniques optimization to
deliver that that kind of user
experiences which I can explain later we
allow join queries we support all kinds
of queries
it's about group I okay I talked about
the front-end library is the front-end
the API here if we use the REST API but
the risk for API is kind of a sequel use
use an interesting format okay I use
this one here so for Astra DB I think I
just talked about briefly Mike and I
have been building and with some other
colleagues from Riverside other couch
players where we build in this 104 last
seven years
is a at Halawa it combines the the
techniques from a semi stretch same
strategy the management parallel
database systems and Hadoop and its
friends into one system it's open source
in Java
essentially it is a pair of database
system with all the support storage
indexing clear processing clear
optimisation clear language the whole
stack okay there's a shared NASA tech
chure we don't take the the other
approaches like Oracle is taking some of
their products we just assume people can
bring in some commodity hardware easily
to make it scalable these are some of
the TB has seven strategy the model we
support be tree archery invert index all
of them that they covered that covers a
lot of data types we use SM for dynamic
data similar to other systems like
and machine and we have our own runtime
engine called Herricks we have our own
query language now we previously it's
called eql coming from xquery now people
don't like xquery we were like sequel so
we change it to sequel plus plus the
plus plus Parsa pooris same structure
party and we're being working with the
codpiece very closely and the recent
announcement from them says cuddliest
decided to use the backend as a db2
support their analytics alright so
that's a one minute overview of has TB
so let me focus on club berry so let me
first talk about this that this api here
and it how how how the middleware talks
to the front end i'm use a very simple
example in earlier demo we use hurricane
but here uses Zika which is very similar
so from the fronton application
perspective it would talk to club areas
through a rest of api because we know
web service architecture is more and
more integrative all right you can you
can plug into any please
and plus by doing this vessel API you
can kind of provide a uniform interface
for the front-end to talk to this layer
which can talk with you can databases
potentially this layer could do even
integration from different databases but
for now we want to each instance only
talk to a single database so this is the
query you turning into Seco is more like
I want to get the number of trees per
state that mentioned the keyword Zika
okay and this is the sequel in adjacent
moment but there is different language
and we would have many different ways to
defined certain properties like what did
I said you're talking to and what kind
of a particles they want to ask opposed
to that that table going to group I on
which attribute or attributes you want
to do the group I and window group Iowa
what kind of aggregation want to do
count some min max they all come to the
configurable user teeth and a quick is
so far now so we just use a standard
echo case so I want to mention a few
things the mirror was doing in to
achieve that that that performance I
mention some of them in meetings this
morning but one thing is caching and not
surprisingly in in in that example if
the user types in hurricane either is
the first time user typed in hurricane
then the the engine will do the work the
middleware would translate that query
into a sequel query back-end or even
multiple queries depend on the semantics
and then the results of the hurricane
query will be restored as as a view and
mature lies inside a database as one of
the tables and from database perspective
they don't know what it is just one of
the tables so it's up to the middleware
to to decide the meaning of this view
and how to maintain it if this is the
the logic we do here and later we'll
cover the case where whatever we do have
a view available there there's a second
technique
and we are doing here the now at the
high level this one looks a little bit a
very overwhelming the main idea is if
the user has typed in drugs Iike a
hurricane and then the system the
middleware has decided to put the
results into a view into a database the
there's still a lot of the issues were
to solve which is how can we make the
view consistent with the backend
database because our principle is we
want to support real-time query
processing meaning when a user types in
a query we want to give the user latest
results that just just came in maybe
five minute ago so to do it
our current solution is the developer
the system admin has to decide the
frequency in which the the middleware
and/or the view and the base table
should be synchronized so let's assume
is one hour so every every hour every
hour the middleware will trigger logic
to tell the database to put the latest
tweets about hurricane the pair tie and
put it there that into the view okay
this is a dumb pipe attack but I put
them but I'm but a minute we're okay but
there's still one issue which is even if
the view is maintained synchronized with
the base table every hour
what if so and now is like a 150 right
150 last time it was single synchronous
at one o'clock there are still some
records that came in in last 50 minutes
so we also want to include this the
latest of trees that came in that last
15 minutes in the results so what a MIDI
world is doing is if at this moment that
we ask for hurricane trees it will first
talk to view which is the full hurricane
trees to fetch all the trees which is
much smaller compared to the entire
1 billion record table in addition it
will also talk to the base table to get
all the trees that just came in last 15
minutes they in the middle to the
combination
sure so in science that do just just
Astro DBS the storage agent or
persistence since all the other parts
are did this this is the second system
anyway so the view maintenance logic is
done by the middleware from an asset EBS
perspective it's just a table just or
just those tits correct about merging
the results yeah that's that's why I'm
in assumption we assume the last the
data that came in last 50 minutes is now
modified an early data that's why we
need this assumption we had a question
so did you know for example in many
gives us and it is didn't come from a
streaming system it's not going to like
the ingestion time for this to get glass
that's right he be here right there and
so on of be kind of too long okay we
pull from let's say I don't know
something that is coming from a you will
have in my house now for for example of
course in any of this sort of inventing
system then how quickly that's one and
the main question there is related truth
but if the your query is a dynamic which
means it's not a register standing clear
then many of the things that are talking
about the views are not a reaction so
how Dan how much how much flexibility
are on the fly so you have a rich API
but that's different from saying can I
write an ad hoc wave just in time and
you can actually search the stream how
is enough yet for the first one about a
bit ingestion we in this architecture we
treat it at a problem for database
system if the data comes from the back
door as long as it is with me in terms
of architecture the Kluber doesn't care
about how it comes in
as long as the data visible through a
query he will get it right so it's
really the DBC business to make sure if
we have fast data that comes in system
they are visible through the query the
transaction properties it should be
guaranteed but it Carberry doesn't
doesn't care about the business just
think for many of the newly coming
events our final kind of situation well
how realistic that assumption is I don't
know all right yeah because the
volunteer develop this software we
assume we treat you as I mean without
pas decision earlier we exceeded your
blab the database at Dropbox even later
than the next time talk by is read about
here yes it may be basically sequel for
now select project UI and group by all
the basic operations this is what we
need and for the for the second issue
the if you want to do a I don't know
what even what do you really mean like
kind of a continuous queries if the user
subscribe so you just quota system
whether the system can periodically or
continuously give the user to update
over that query is that what do you mean
modalism actually doesn't answer that
question you have never seen this before
right right so there's a distinction
between a query template versus
parameter of that way I'm talking about
the query self and so far in the current
way up to the view materialization we we
assume each of you has a keyword for now
so we have a hurricane view we could
have a like a thermal view we could have
a zigg of you know no oh yeah it's or
not on the fly that's all the difference
I think in some of the earlier work
people have to do some kind of all
flying like a collecting history
grandmother information the one person
we follow is we start from scratch the
views will be on a fly created in
maintained we don't do offline data
cubes we don't do offline
what clue analysis and see which of the
views would be should be virtualized and
one more thing that's very real to our
case is say and this thought is domain
text is very common and user can tepee
arbitrary keywords it's very hard to
produce decide what kind of keyboard you
can provide so won't do everything on
the fly there's no offline process a pro
step
do you always maintain the view inside
the same database that the original data
center do you also provide for being
able to do that separate system yes so
question about do we always put the
views into the same database but
currently we we do we we assumed we'd
see do backend database as a storage
layer and when I put some results there
you do it but you impossible can always
have a separate database just to store
views right yeah that's doable we didn't
do it
and the okay so other questions so I'm
just curious whether the keywords the
search of exact keyword search or so far
we haven't done any in the advanced like
a expansion fun to mention who's Tammy
and nothing we have not done yet this is
only a kind of first step I was doing
who is working on this a foot has to
first feature there
we know how to do it just a matter of
time
next known as say is back to your
tutorial right hey what if the views are
not available I mean the first time user
it gives the query hurricane there's
nothing inside that database in it has
abuse how can we do it so we people here
are expert in the topic so when we first
developed a prototype one year ago
that's the first one is that you use
experience which is really troublesome
because whenever I show demo I always
try to show the keyword I have issued
before but in the audience people can
give me as an operative keyword this is
what I use experienced which is no nice
so what we decided to there are many
different approaches what we decided to
do is this approach which is you you do
a query slicing okay I want to go leave
a deeper to put
topic because I talked to some people in
this audience
the reason we take this approach is we
want to treat the backend database as a
black box we do not want to make any
change of database we just assume you
have a standard API maybe a sicko API
and I I want to develop a solution that
does not have any a priori knowledge
about your histogram I can do this kind
of use experience and let me show you
the example here so what do we do if I
show the in solution what do we do the
very simple
the one more assumption we make we
assume in your data or a table to be
more specific you can pick one attribute
using which you can slice your query
this is a something we make so in this
example we assume we pick the time of
the tweet at a dimension so as a
measuring in the medium this morning I
have it did of about two years if I do a
query for all the trees it takes long
time to finish and instead I can keep
the results first give you the results
for one week and in the mid second week
a third a week and I hopefully when I by
dividing this big query to this a small
queries but call them mini queries each
of the mini query is more and more
responsive the same time we want to
progressively give the updating okay so
one very simple solution is the
following as I said I do it a week by
week okay so this is the behavior
so so in this demo in this
implementation you know first
implementation would just fix the
interval size like a one week or one
month so I do one query to give me all
the results for January and then results
for February result of of March and
appears them together okay we see a lot
of issues here
first issue is skewness it is not null
is a uniform distributed so of course we
assume there is a kind of an index
structure on this attribute but
accessing that index structure you can
the mini queries much faster osteo you
in this case since the the distribution
of that dimension is non-uniform you get
is a behavior sometimes it can be can be
really can be really fast sometimes can
be very slow especially in the hurricane
example you can see last summer there's
a peak once you go to that range then
the engine is very busy processing that
query use a width for a long time this
is one drawback the other drawback is
even for the database itself even if the
dispersers uniform okay still your
database is busy with many other queries
even in a multi-tenant environment to
your your virtual machine may be a
serving in lots of different tenants so
even it'll be heavy err for the database
can be very unpredictable slicing so for
a user's point of view next I have an
average query average aggregate so when
you underneath you're doing some slicing
that I don't know about yes right so
you're giving me an answer for let's say
some slice and that has a certain
average now once you add the second
slice that average may go up or down
change drastically so as a user what do
I see did you see this
so what are we our system doing is keep
the results progressively I think that
if you look at something like online
aggregation there was some at least yeah
confidence interval yeah yeah this one
took me to some degree you can say these
are also one way to the sampling right
I'm doing sampling in a very consistent
way and I don't have any assumption but
institution that's why I do it I cannot
give you any confidence if you do some
like a random sampling or some of the
work you did the team here is doing well
you look at what Chehalis ting has done
like a 20 years ago on on aggregation
some of the approaches have this
assumption that the database engine
supports random sampling and we don't
have the luxury here we want to take the
approach where I just have a database it
in there I don't know what's inside it
and I don't want to modify the database
and can I do something in the middle
where there can be very self adaptive so
in this whole solution when we started
the system the caliber system it doesn't
know anything about database
except of course API and so the
distribution of that dimension I don't
know especially since the user can type
in any keyword I cannot build a
histogram for every keyword or even
combination of keywords and even the
behavior of the database engine can be
very unpredictable suddenly becomes
faster sometimes can be slower and the
middleware should be able to adjust
itself to give you this very smooth
experience so this is a protic of course
it which is why it depends on scenario
if you have the access to source code
you have the luxury to modify your
source code to provide this random
sampling of interface you should go with
that approach but the approach we take
assumes you just have a blackbox time
and to encourage right where's you know
you have one attribute
using which you can do personalizing not
necessary so but you can go deeper to
see that I think you can come up with
some requirements on us
the the slashing attribute but in this
query is a group by state and Cooper
state and what we're doing is we just
first get all the high love get all the
results for say for January and then
into the count and those whatever common
is kind of other the results are
equitable right assumable or you can
keep some smoking resolves you can't you
put them together but how about the
little common afford assassin
attribution should be very very minimal
this you're picking it up big wavy great
right so I'm just asking whether it's
configurable that you were taking me to
be by week or state-by-state because you
could also do it state by state right
yeah
so we could we make the stop we try to
make the made aware a coffee crippled by
a ballerina you just say I do it a week
by week or a month but I want to mention
that you could take the approach but
that experience another present exactly
I showed here if you just do it on a
fixed interval due to the behavior of
the distribution and the date of the
engine the the times of delivering
results
Auburn are not very smooth we want to
keep the users very smooth or what we
call the rhythmic approach that's
exactly that the solution we came up
with we just finished a paper just maybe
two weeks ago so the idea is the
following at high level how can we how
can a middleware decide a slicing
interval for the back end to make sure
the execution time of the mini query can
be finished in the kind of fixed time
okay suppose that let's say two seconds
suppose when developer system you want
to say the middleware should give the
front end update every two seconds
suppose this is a configuration and
you're Monica Monica dancing rhythm here
how can you make sure every two seconds
you keep the front-end update instead of
using a delivering result at different
times so the key challenge is how can
the middleware mod or the behavior of
this distribution and also model to be
a view of the engine at the play box and
then be adapted by itself there is one
of course a time constraint nuisance
enterocytes first you if a view there is
a constraint I get that is an optimizing
function there's no there's no we in
this formation we don't assume you had
to finish by certain deadlines we don't
have the assumption well you don't have
assumptions you don't know we just want
to give the results whatever time it
takes they had to give the results we
don't have this deadline ocean here the
focus of this work example mod model
more by the wisdom how can I give you
the results using this fix to second
windows so we assumed this to second
this parameter is given by the Perseus
madman so me and the system admin you
won't develop a system you say I want to
give the reason user update every two
seconds two seconds a parameter you can
do you can be two seconds could be one
second could be five seconds and nor the
slice exactly so so that the middle has
to take out the the sighting time this
exactly you should wear resolve so the
system Intel's system tells the system
give the user update every two seconds
if the the either it is this itself is
over constrained or it is a situation
that multiple solutions eyeball I can
sort of slice in some 15 ways then is
there a desirable properties of this or
an optimizing function for this okay
we're trying to get looking at you know
let's say you fix do it
non-deterministically certain behavior
another time and given that there's no
statistical basis for it I don't know
how to interpret that's a purple of this
like okay so so using a very simple
example we
I said because there are three different
ways to deliver results okay the first
way I just asked for the whole range and
these are called schedule and this
schedule takes six seconds to finish but
during a six second user has a wage okay
a second schedule magically you can give
the user update every two seconds and
all these four queries run in the same
time of course all together it takes
down the time he seconds but the update
is very regular very rhythmic okay
the third approach also issues the four
queries and the first query took a one
second the second core took three
seconds the third thing once that took
one second the four stick took three
seconds so this fire four different
queries they finished different times
okay now if you just whenever you get a
result you keep the result back to user
now this one the users see the result
out one second and then the user will
wait for some time after two seconds has
no update the user has to wait for like
one more second to get the results okay
and the third one the user get the
results immediately after one second
then the fourth one the user still needs
to wait for like a one second after the
2000 deadline
okay so back to your question sorted so
I have three different ways to teach
ourselves how can we quantify the
quality here right we need to come up
with a notion to say which is better
okay and now when come up with the
metric there's no single answer here
right so but I give you our answer to
the question we consider two things in
this formulation one total running time
ideally want to make as small as
possible
right because overall I don't want to
reuse a user to wait of a long time a
second thing we also care about is if
there's a pace and I say two seconds
that means every time the user gets
updated the next time user gets update
you want the user it does not you do not
want use it to wait for more than two
seconds okay if the next query comes in
after two second deadline the longer
user waste the more panelling had to pay
he had oh he had to pay so so what we
the problem the second issue is we were
called a smooth smoothness of the result
delivery which is suppose this is your
previous mini query that ends here the
maintenance pace you can still wait for
some time for it for the mini where to
give the results and suppose this is a
two second window and but the demands
clear can be issued right after the
first one was finished okay but if this
one took a longer than expected if it
finishes here then during this period
the user has to wait
so the second factor we had to consider
in this whole quality metric is how much
delay the user has to wait ideally we
want to minimize the total running time
we also want to minimize that to the
number of a waiting time for the user so
the solution we come up with out the
answer we have is a combination of the
two factors the total running time which
is we call the T and the total delay and
we use a second factor constant to put
aside how much apparently want to give
to a thirty-day okay of course we can
talk about whether this one is really
the golden standard but the idea is
there combination up with post factors
and if you use a very small slice say
one millisecond
yes then di will be basically zero yes
this cost will be higher because you're
sending a lot of a query back-end and
how do you model that cause uh for now
we are just better time again we don't
know how many CPU cycles the resource
available in database system and we
don't have the access so they either the
way just a matter of time
of course they be I be excited to
database resources you can come up with
a better way to model the cost I mean
are these many queries are they being
executed in parallel some of them are so
far in a kernel implementation we assume
they are found sequentially we did an
experiment where the media work could
send the monikers at same time our fun
thing is you are kind of overdoing your
work right you're competing resources
with other people so you could do it but
better for our solution we assume we do
the sequentially
okay Fred you the main three that we are
saying is running time or is it like
this one this one yeah here's a total
running time but when you try to
optimize figure this out what are
coordinating a planning phase right
access to that we don't have it so this
is Monica ruler to measure your equality
and they're in a beginning I will try to
formulate a kind of an optimization
problem we found is really hard because
it's a nun problem everything had
chained as you run to a schedule so what
do we do is we take a quit approach
meaning every time when a January the
next mini query based on this function I
try to be very greedy I don't claim any
optimality at the end when a generator
scheduled I use this function to measure
the height of my schedule so I don't I
don't go with this optim attic guarantee
I'm just greedy okay so so this is a
framework of what we are doing we call
it drum which stands for delivery not
drum resolves upon my barstools
okay so more like the rhythm way way you
use a drum you see the the pay is you
had to meet the requirement so the idea
I mean you have seen this structure in
many other places the whole framework is
very adaptive meaning you have a query
and the middleware will generate in each
of the January some very conservative
conservative media queries but using
very small intervals
okay keep some resolves and then you
send a mini query to the back end and
then the back and keep is keep see
results the middleware also keeps track
of the numbers performance and those and
that information will be fed into this
module to model the behavior of the
engine that information will be reused
by the generator to decide next mini
query so that's why it's very self
adaptive so this adapts the width of the
slices that you're doing to
generate the mini queries correct do you
also do any adaptation about choosing a
different dimension along which to do
that we don't do it
the reason is from the user experience
the perspective the UI is fixed right in
your example it's always time you know
the sample is always time we'll fix it
because if you tried the million sensors
to the space the UI doesn't
non-significant so this is an area okay
so now talk about details we want to
model the relationship between the size
in time at one time so the one thing we
do have is a regression model so we do
in linear equation but you can pick any
other location model Hey well any
regression model is not an economy
perfect we also have a model to model
that the behavior or the errors okay and
I think maybe RS spend almost like 40
minutes in I think get a me idea what
are we are doing here so if if it don't
mind
okay just wrap up this way move on the
next one here you get any idea we try to
use this middleware to respond to
queries without making a very strong
assumption by the backend database this
is what is constant yeah we don't we we
were talking to our HCI faculty to see
we can tell you the study and I think
this is their expertise and like every
two cops we haven't done it yet but if
I'm Miriam biasing perception we see the
fixing interval it doesn't look good
considering the time right so what I was
thinking is that almost the time might
be dating if it might be that you
applies only for one second however the
amount of data that comes for that one
one son one second me a lot so shouldn't
you consider the slicing as some
estimation of how many data will come on
that slice and
exactly we when we decide the slicing
interval with we do consider the factor
that's that's the end the answer is a
combination of the question and in our
model we try to be intuitively if I want
to finish the query within two seconds
by using linear model maybe I should
have used maybe it's seven days but I
use a seven day window I have a I have a
risk of missing that line so I should be
little bit conservative me by using
maybe five days or four days so that is
already captured by the error model so I
[Laughter]
think there's no first time people such
as us to user studies I think we should
do it
be sure to it I'm recorded so I want to
use a romanian time to talk about a
second system okay this is decided this
is enough slicing how much to slice an
hour in this case as far as I could
understand simple histogram I don't have
the history is a virtual database
because in release hard I had it it's
cut this morning if the user than
tapping some after keywords how can I
build a histogram for some key where I
don't know a priori I don't do I start
from scratch the settings are different
all right so I want to take the meantime
talk about a second system which is to
me also very exciting I did a lot of
work in text processing I did a startup
about text processing and I feel text is
a very rich domain and a lot of
opportunities the new system I am
building is called a text era in the
earlier after I used text to be later we
renamed it because an on database system
at a high level it is a system that come
their supports cloud-based text
processing ok and I'm going to show you
the reason is everybody in this room can
write a code
some people without IT background the
kind of radical but how can we make it
easier for these people including us to
do some text processing very easily
without writing a single arm code right
if I can finish one thing within five
minutes I do want to do it in one hour
it's about the cost okay so what we're
building is a web service context era
using which a system can easily drag and
drop some Pisco operators to formulate a
workflow hey I didn't so any software is
a business web so here I'm also using
Twitter as an example and so I can just
say look at scan refresh the page so I
want to allow a person to analyze trees
without writing a single line of code so
I can say I do a scan okay and now a lot
of tables there I pick a one table
called
with the data for last one week and then
I can just see the resource and we know
it's a select story with a limit so two
operators and run a query and I should
be able to see some of the sample trees
okay maybe within within ten seconds
again to it so but that's not innovating
so let's do more analysis suppose I only
want to look at all the trees mentioning
a particular keyword
say hurricane so I go here at was search
two
keyword search and I need to specify the
attribute and the keyword I used like a
hurricane hurricane and I gave a name of
the results like as operator search
results so I linked these two operators
and these two operators so this is a new
new query okay so you can click each of
them you see this one should have
working here okay so other knowledge is
suppose I want to enter the recognition
okay so what I can do is I go to this
menu option I pick antigen recognition
and pick one of the attributes and I
want to locate pick one of the types
now verb suppose I want to look at
locations okay
and I say location results okay I want
to see is there a notion of ranking is a
notion of top 10 or because we have a
limit
you know databases people are not good
at ranking we give you tear there you
think that's the difference between I
already debate the annoying it my
experience that is an operator that is
incredibly sensitive to context then
whether I want to recognize products
historical figures other stuff now how
can you have a sort of a general-purpose
single entity recognition of great haste
and this standard
anti recognizer is wrapping stamping
anarchy we're a pollution we wrapped up
in our P we wrap in our tak with wrap
use case but when you when you do it
still what what you're positioning this
as is a one-stop-shop for all all sorts
of domains yes right so in a way
whatever you wrap still has to
generalize and curse is in your
experience is that the case or is there
some way to customize the it bone
if you look at mute ablution right
ablution machine very powerful search
engine stemming ranking a phrase search
stamp and multi-language support they
are available we can wrap it and bring
back to you and some of the operators
are using machine 7rp standardized the
rapid by same time if the user wants to
add their own logic we should allow user
to do it which is a query builder and
all I'm doing these are individual
components and I am just by necessary by
planning but a workflow kind of correct
and it's just that it's a visual thing
and the boxes are what they are right
what is the semantics of this workflow
following for each one figuring out what
it is and whatever is semantics is I
take the results and put it in this pipe
and that's it right
is this how this is something else is
for text is a minute for text do we have
a solution on the market I don't say
work your work on the challenge email is
fine but I don't see any institution on
the market there are solutions that a
standalone software package is like nine
rapid minor or tricks these are a few
solutions either open source or
proprietary there they are not open a
web based in the cloud based and from a
user perspective they do not want to
install software we will we're sort of
to ask the question in a different way
let's say I firmly believe in the VEX
entity extractor as being what would it
take for me to actually integrate one
specific entity recognizer in your is
that possible yeah it is possible we
first of all it took us about one a half
years so that we just your Marsten yeah
you know saying and doing the different
it took a lot out under which to step
the few things of we what we are doing
I want to summarize the feeling
one-to-one accessibility if you you you
have your own lottery or even some
package you want to wrap we want to make
that process very easy we want to
support the Python we run propose Java
and our these are common languages how
can we allow the developer to wrap their
own logic into this whole pipeline
that's one we had to do it
second is debug the ability and when you
have this a long-running job on a very
large number records the whole execution
can take a long time how can you give
the user some kind of a progress report
of where you are in the whole execution
and allow the user to even pause one of
the operators and to something that
investigation of the state of that
operator those intermediate results even
do some that Italy need to see where
that record comes from we had to allow
you to keep pocket if I know like
principally let's say so all names that
have a middle name that's a single
initial arm is recognized how do I
actually have then then enable that
feedback right it's one thing to
recognize that it's another thing to
actually systematically modify my entity
recognition component yes so far we we
don't have a little feedback mechanism
right now we don't have it yet
I mean we no no I mean you look and we
talk about the structure factor right
these kind of software's they are very
powerful in terms of allowing a user to
highlight some other places and then
they can recommend some some some rules
here and we are not there yet I mean but
the Donner row we let me talk about the
kernel focus accessibility debug ability
and usability and one more thing we care
about a bit about the potential
scalability and so far the whole thing
runs on a single engine and and no
nothing can prevent us from running one
Operator in a parallel environment
because we know text processing can be
very very expensive can take hours or
days to finish so you can paralyze it
the execution of each operators to this
cluster then that's even more powerful
so
futilities have not been done yet which
is only the initial prototype and the
good news is for for both systems I'm
presenting here they are used by people
as I said in my hog abstract we are
working with some UCI researchers enough
of my CS they are working on public
health politics to use social media to
do their analysis and they love the
first demo because they can easily see
the data and the also you this one here
because they do not want the right
program you do not want to install
software you do not want to apply
patches and this is the big advantage of
the cloud-based trend I mean everybody
here knows how important trend the cloud
is and I we believe even if it t the
idea of either weapon minor or or 9 but
push it to the cloud and make it very
easy to use and make the the execution
detached from the front-end and the user
can access the execution from anywhere
even allow multiple users to share that
execution interface is a very powerful
that's why now Google Docs is very very
very easy to use because multiple people
can share the same document this
infrastructure can allow multiple
developers to share the same workflow
without using a remote desktop so this
this is a I believe it is the trend and
a lot of a new challenges we have to
solve in this new architecture here I
was telling a story imputing this ok you
got any idea but we wrap a few hello
seeing in RTK Stephan RP maybe this
future module we're going to wrap it and
then we want to make it extensible by
allowing the user to write out their own
logic
so those things are really happening
here so where was the technical part
tech number you already got a second
technical part let me give you maybe one
slide here and one interesting thing is
how to so if you people some people as a
question how is it different from
database engine hey Halawa is all about
operators forming a bag well Adela
the artists name but the main difference
is against our database system
people don't interact with operators
people interrupt the system we use in
sequel it's a string but here you the
user can interact with each other okay
so the architectures work different a
second difference is inside database
system how many operators we have maybe
30 or 40 at the most right but in this
text domain there's so many given
operations can do the number of
operators is much much larger
III heard rather man or they they
clearly have more than one thousand
dollars for different purposes because
they have this architecture whole
architecture that allows a new user
developer to contribute new operators
the whole thing work because the whole
thing is very open very extensible now
while you develop a such an engine - how
can we make the easy for a new operator
to implement it that's very different
from a database case where everything is
under control but here is more
open-ended
so what do we do in our engine is every
operator has a kind of a kind of a
descriptor in a JSON format the
descriptor has all information parties
on Twitter in addition to the code of
course you have to have a code logic the
description could have like how many
input was an input arity was the output
arity and whether even you leave it even
the front-end what kind of icon wonder
you want to use and what kind of a
description want to want to attach to
this to this operator and from a
developer's perspective as long as you
use a framework to describe a new
operator with the code and the metadata
the whole thing will be integrated to
the whole system
there may not be the serialization logic
there so you just write that I think so
first of all we have not done that you
have part yet right because I'm not
saying every package can be can be
wrapped up all right live is modern
appear a purple but there's certain
protocol the person has to follow well
what's the input with the output
right so but I want to identify the
commonality and make it easier for the
developer to write a piece of code so
far the way we we integrated a RTK which
is in Python is pretty interesting
because we tried different ways to
include Python in our travel engine and
the one approach is a used Java class to
interpret all the different Python code
the other one is running a Python as a
separator in process and their JVM and
the patent process use the IPC to
communicate we take a second approach
but even for a second prod there's a one
question which is how the DVM and the
Python process share share information
back and forth and how you can minimize
the overhead by doing batching I know
those things need to be pick out
something like sequel server integration
services which has a very similar in the
sense that there are a bunch of bacon
operators which you as a user can
connect for your tasks and you see and
they also have custom script operators
that you can write your own script and
put it into the thing as long as it
meets certain input/output criteria you
can plug it in anywhere into the yeah
since those kinds of engines have been
paid right so what you see is the new
challenges because it's text processing
I'm not saying this idea of formulating
workflow using tracker trouble operators
new Microsoft did it and Rev a miner did
it and I believe that the uniqueness
here is the cloud I believe if you pick
some idea you can make a similar
argument why does my cursor move from
office to office 306 yet to move
everything so cloud and that is
architecture safety previously you've
run the whole thing on your single
desktop I don't know that the software
major I never I saw some some GUI to
form a little clearer I saw that
interface I don't know what that was
that's the one you talked about but in
general I believe the software you
talked about is something running on a
local machine
ETL length
I will be targeting right but I don't
know what this is a copyist assault well
III don't know yet but but I feel feels
or other passionately to your point with
the examples you gave all of its physics
if I won't work not make sense he's
questioning that but from a technical
perspective James I don't have a perfect
answer to a question because that we are
also exploring I I really do the project
based on my kind of feeling here but
it's like people I see people want is
one this this is my showdowns are not
talking of answer but if I go deeper I
believe first went with a cloud there's
a very big potential of automatically
scale of the whole computation right if
you have a job that's very expensive to
run then in a cloud you have a much
better freedom to scale to the lounge
multiple virtual machines to paralyze
some of the operators that the web gives
the opportunity I don't think yes that
one with a new opportunity you can now
explore on a single desktop right in
addition in terms of the the user
experience I think is very different of
course you might not say is a technical
part in Wendy's on the architecture the
since we're using this client-server
architecture the execution of your logic
should be detached from your content
well you can easily set up an open a new
browser and attached to that one here
right so you can say it's engineering
technical we don't know but you had to
think about this whole thing verb
differently you can say the idea has
been implemented by wrap in a minor and
rapid manner is using everything as a
java program of running a single machine
but I believe
software's like a rapid manner have
spent a significant amount of effort on
the even all new ideas on there that's
why it's very hard for them to migrate
to the web cloud they can't they have a
burden they had a care of with them
right before we saw from scratch from
day one we do
web interface so maybe one year two
years down the road I have more
Technomancer to do you're gonna have to
beat UNIX pipes
I mean hey you know basic basic it's
very interesting to listen to the
questions everybody here's a database
person thing they would spice man boot
that this kind of thing was it then that
units clients were actually used exactly
for this it was except it's not Jason
it's a different data model it's you
know comma or acceptable space separated
fields carriage returns separated never
say the yeah exactly yeah and you know
you talk about the cloud in terms of
scale up but I probably the first thing
that people would worry about is is how
to get parallelism on a multi-core
machine that with shared memory because
they're just there are a lot of
performance issues there we know just
for database processing query processing
to get the most out of the machine and I
have a hard time thinking about text
processing that this is such a scale
that you would go to multiple machines
to get there uh I have 1 billion toys to
give it in a user that not want to wait
for a long time
so having having the ability to run the
whole thing on 100 machines will help
for sure
prepare to your question I agree with
you that you're on a single machine
there is a lot of potential to paralyze
the computation using multiple cores but
strategically back to a certain question
I will now focus on that one yet because
that you should also exists on a single
desktop software you are not suggesting
you what you're really talking or design
a fantasy in terms of the machine
architects in the cloud how does it work
you have these individual boxes I can
sort of think of them
a bit of like microservices I can say
hey they're their own cluster they have
their own validation logic they run on
their own you know in their own VMs
right and just up front of them if you
need an orchestration service where they
send it back and connect all these micro
services if you really want to be kind
of cloud negative you should think in
terms of micro services and that is
right now but look there are all kinds
of issues right I mean in that case your
storage completely just have a REST API
through the share communicating and
that's pretty much it so it's in some
ways a narrow pipe yeah I assume
anything but there are what side of the
network they may not be on the same rack
or you can't make any assumption on what
those machines are so to get there the
question is to get the right performance
architectural what are you assuming so
as you said but the model is not new
you're going to cloud but with that
comes a question what is running where
what it is shared where is the network
what how much has been transmitted
across the network and what are the
assumptions very good point there there
are lot of questions about architecture
we could run each of the operators as a
micro service using some standard
roughly restful api i currently we're
looking at the architecture where we use
cutting the cut actor model isn't that
much so we are we hopefully Patti now
this quarter I you know this year we're
going to switch the whole thing to the
actual model because so the idea is the
idea
each operator has is is running as a
thread with a separate EQ and all the
different operators
communicate with each other by sending
messages to the queue and then a big
advantage of this architecture is I can
pause it because each of the actors is
running using a thread like a positive
thread currently I'm using a single
thread using the pull model so we plan
to switch the push model with other
actors funny
so you know I have a kind of feeling I
don't have any
to support it which is micro-service
might be too expensive I think I think
just asking you in this spectrum where
you say I guess the actor models be more
should be more efficient because it is
the same framework using the inter
thready communication that much would be
cheaper than sending a HTTP request here
there is my gut feeling so very likely a
vehicle we go to an action model in fact
the better the the club the the Twitter
map demo you saw earlier you seen didi
using the actor model
it's already in the actor model for the
user scholar but this one we countries
were using Java ok alright so I I
reached the end of my talk but I'm gonna
say one more thing which is in this text
domain machine learning models are used
a very very common and one common
question people ask is in a whole
pipeline of
data analysis machine learning is a very
important step where does machine
learning fit into the this whole
architecture so the way I see it is we
have this back and ask you to be running
at the database system to do ingestion
and we used the the cloud barrier to the
visualization and then we use a texture
our code one we call it text to be that
does the GUI based formulation and this
whole suite of solutions can be used to
help you to the dedicated preparation
for machine learning you can use it to
sit to store data visualize data and
analyze the data and then once you just
host Ritu to Ken to get some like
prepare some data or label the data then
you can train a model here so you get
one but I mean here so you can use the
hook in the trainer model model is more
like maybe a matrix with all the
parameters right just a file and then
this model can be integrated back to
either to text era as one of the
operators once we finish the the kind of
UDK WTF feature or a1 the model data is
being ingested into the backend database
this model can be used
okay UDF to do some offline processing
well even runtime wiring to the
visualization for those trees you can
even use UDF to to the so here you have
this database that you have a data and
you have you have access to the scheme
of that database to translate the query
to to the sequel query is that correct
correct
wait the middleware has the access to
data what I don't understand is in
realistic either you're a tutor or a
turret party right when you're in a
third party you get this data and stored
now you have access to this data so
where are you exactly I can't use it Oh
Oh a sarmatians you have the back-end
database has a large amount of data and
the middleware knows the API is keema
but the middleware is more like
accelerator so some cookies monitor data
warehousing accelerator that sits on top
of your database returning database and
again in a year so previously the
application of your talks our data visit
directly to ask queries but those clears
can be slowed by by by putting
cloudberry in in between which also
knows the database schema this layer can
use all the techniques to meet those
queries at the application layer much
faster this is the position to stress
this operator but they also do the
prowling they have a data and also they
do salt and all those new clients
it's the cavalry as a general purpose
software it's not just what we're your
database can be anything so it's not
specific to Twitter okay thanks a lot
for anything
[Applause]